i'm curious maude for you i mean your
character has been so interesting over
these seasons because she is
really sort of the observer
what is it like to have this
play become her focus this season and to
really like put on a full production
what was it like to do that and to read
the script for that
yeah i mean sam and i sort of talked
about it um
it's loosely inspired by me in high
school being like a theater tyrant so
i i understood
that
aspect of it but it was so crazy we were
doing like a full play in front of a
full
real audience so it was it was scary
yeah we were all like austin and
the other cast members i don't know i
don't know how to not give it away but
we
yeah we got the
the jitters we all had the stage
but it was so fun it was so so fun
what do you think it says about her as a
character
i mean i think
she bottles so much up so
when she gets angry and frustrated she
doesn't really know how to deal with it
and so she sort of lashes out in like
sort of ridiculous ways and
yeah i think i mean lexi's really smart
and
hard-working and i think she's sort of
also very
controlling like when she i think so
much in her life is
crazy and falling apart and brew's
losing it cassie's losing it and she's
like okay this is my one thing i'm like
i have control over it and i'm gonna get
it right
if it's the last thing
i do so yeah that's
sydney and alexa how was it to shoot the
scene in the hot tub i mean cindy what
was it like to be the one
having to do the vomiting and alexa i
mean even though it's fake is it still
gross to be on the receiving end of that
that wasn't fake it
it came out a little well
she vomited um it was very disgusting
yeah
it was really
it was like so it was this clear pipe
that was like a little tube that they
like weaved behind my back and then into
my mouth like a horse
bit
and so during the scene they would fill
my mouth
with the throw up and i had to sit there
as if nothing was going into my mouth
and let it fill and fill and fill and
fill and then throw up
i was really worried i was actually
going to throw up
yeah i was gonna say i mean is it ever
fun to do something like that or is it
just gross all around
that one was just gross
well i'm curious too i mean sydney you
you were so great on the white lotus
what do you think your character on the
white lotus would think of cassie and
vice versa i mean do you think they
would hate each other would they be
friends would they even register on each
other's radar in any way
i think olivia would walk by and just
roll her eyes like cassie be like girls
not have your [ __ ] together
how do you think cassie would feel about
her
i think cassie would be very intimidated
by olivia because olivia portrays such a
put together
sophisticated
uh character and i think cassie would be
just
not on the same
playing level field
alexa this season we see maddie bond
with minka kelly's character and and she
seems to sort of put some things in
perspective for maddie yeah what do you
think maddie learns from her
um i think maddie just
finally feels like she has
a
a female mentor someone who's older than
her i don't think i think we see in
season one that she doesn't really uh
respect the decisions that her parents
have made
so she sees this woman in this gorgeous
house with these gorgeous clothes and
you know she seems so put together
so she's i think she's just she really
takes in what she says and i think
it helps her feel like minka kelly's
character helps her feel like the
decisions she's made with the
relationship is nor it's normal like
it's
it's normal to have these like toxic
relationships when you're younger
because you're learning and so i think
she helps her realize like i i did this
too this is not what you have to stay
with you know um
you can move on it's just a phase or
whatever
and so i think she just helps her
realize what
isn't true love and what could be
mod i also really thought the
relationship between lexi and fesco is
so interesting
of all the people what do you think it
is about him that she finds herself
drawn to
um
i think i mean
the thing that's so interesting about
angus's character is like
he's so sweet and he has got like such a
he's got like such sweet eyes but
he also
is sort of like forced to be in this
position and i i think he doesn't really
want that for himself he has so many
other like dreams and goals and we see
that through the season and their
conversations but
i think
she just finds him fascinating and she's
never met anyone like him and i think
vice versa and so
but deep down they sort of like
have really similar interests and like
make each other laugh and like they're
just buddies even though it's pretty
no one would see it coming but
i think they just got along really well
yeah it's funny how jarring it is in the
middle of everything else going on that
there's this like sweet pure
relationship with all of this other like
total insanity happening
sydney how do you feel about cassie and
nate can you see
maddie's point
about you know not hooking up with your
friend's boyfriend even if he is an ex i
mean how do you feel about that whole
dynamic
i think there's valid points on both
sides but
of course i play cassie so i can't judge
you too harshly
but
she acts out of love just like pure
utter
anxious
crazy love
well i appreciate you guys talking to me
about the show you all
just broke my heart this season so much
insanity happens so thank you for
talking to me about it
you